good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
councillors
members of the public thank you for your
attendance could you remain upstanding
for the council prayer
almighty god grant to us all needed
guidance wisdom and judgment
as we face the tasks before us and
enable us now
and always worthily to discharge the
sacred trust
placed by the people in our hands amen
i'd like to welcome those who are
switched
into who are attending the meeting by
way of live stream
uh we're delighted to have you join this
meeting
and we also have a zoom
attendance with councillor lindsay
abbott
are there any other apologies councillor
pottinger
thank you second that moved and seconded
any discussion
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
against kerry
oh yes okay
you have um counselor
um okay
he's not a counselor yet
i can't call him counsellor
thank you i'll now ask uh mr
marcus slash to come forward please
congratulations
declare that i will faithfully and
impartially
declare that i will faithfully and
impartially and according to the best of
my skill and judgment and according to
the best of my skill and judgment
execute and perform in the best
interests of invercargill city
district the powers and authorities
and duties vested in executing perform
in the best interests of the indication
the powers authorities and duties vested
in
me as a member of the invercargill city
council
by virtue of the local government act
2002
were opposed on me as a member of the
indica city council they voted for the
local government act 2002.
the local government official
information and meetings act
1987 or any other act
the local government official
information in meetings act 1987
or any other act
okay everybody put the camera in place
i was about to melt it down
now public forum nobody here
thank you any changes in the interest
register
all right changes
uh receiving and confirming the minutes
let's start with the minutes of the
meeting of council held on the 26th
of january be confirmed
move to worship second national worship
and second any discussion
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
against carried the minutes of the
meeting of the infrastructural services
committee
held in the second of february
to be received
alex happy to move those second those
your worship moved in second any
discussion
questions put it to the vote all in
favor say aye
aye aye against carrie minutes of the
meeting of the performance
policy and partnerships committee held
on the 9th of february to be received
move that your worship second
you've been seconded
any discussion note i put it to the vote
all in favor say
i i carried
the minutes of the meeting of the bluff
community board held on the 15th of
february
you received i was actually absent at
the meeting but i could move the minutes
read the read the minutes i'll do that
because
otherwise there's no one there i'll move
that those minutes be accepted i'll
second those pray for me
come to the lewis put it to the vote all
in favor say
aye
minutes of the meeting of the
extraordinary performance policy and
partnerships committee held on the 16th
of february
again you worship happy to move those
happy to second that
moved and seconded any further
discussion put it to the vote all in
favor say i
i carried
okay so now we'll move on to the reports
being received you worship this one all
set of minutes i think
the minutes of the meeting of the
extraordinary infrastructure or services
committee held on the 16th of
february you received i'm happy to move
those your worship in council
pottinger's
absence second lab
moved and seconded
report on working together an update
from
projects governor's group
peter thompson is in attendance with
jane parker
to speak on the stage
thank you worship um so the
governance group has had its first
meeting and this is the first project
update in terms of working together
can i say that in terms of this the
governance group
has endorsed recommendations that come
from each of the working five working
groups
and is now presenting that to council
for discussion
pete thompson is going to take us
through the report as i understand
welcome to the meeting thank you through
the chair
just to pick up on jeff's comment that
each of the recommendations have come by
the work
that has uh come from the five rivers
as part of working on working together
framework
i'll take the report as read but perhaps
that we can do a page turn and speak
through each of the
items as well recommendations and i'll
start perhaps with terms of reference
for the project governance group
which is appendix a
so three changes have been made to this
terms of reference the first is the
deputy mayor who's added
to the membership of the government's
group
the second just to note that the word
progress to the minister
is via the department of internal
affairs and thirdly
that the pgg will approve the purpose
and deliverables
of each work group so to just frame it
out a little bit
each work group has both a purpose and a
set of deliverables
in which we're delivering those will be
endorsed by the pgg
second item index b is the terms of
reference of the external appointees
some minor changes we made to these
terms of reference they're listed here
but i'll just
go over those so we've expanded on the
background in terms of reference
simply for clarity we've clarified that
the external appointees will attend
most meetings and workshops and or sort
of the council table
and finally that the project framework
should be amended by the project
governance group
as the project develops and what we mean
by that is
the project is set out into four phases
and we're currently in
phase two
index working on working together
uh as i mentioned previously phase two
um identifying changes
and improvements and begin the
implementation of some of the
deliverables
when reach the point of phase three this
will be the continuation of changes and
improvements analysis at the moment
this will begin in july
and finally case four will begin in
january 2022
and run through to june 2022
so there's a chance that the faces will
overlap this is outlined in the report
but the appendix here is priceless to
you finally for briefs
and budget estimates for working groups
we have
updated all the working groups um
in the last week and signed off the core
briefs and budgets for the following
four groups supporting the committee
structure
the training for committee chairs and
councillors supporting the mayor and
chief executive
curriculum and developing media
protocols
we are still to finalize the strategic
process work group
but this work group is being put on hold
for a mid check
in march april this year as a result of
rcp consultation
clarifying the role of the deputy mayor
at icc there were some recommendations
in the thompson report
that has outlined the work that's going
on in this space good progress
i've already discussed the strategic
project since supporting rcp workstream
and finally the developing media
protocols of bringing the community
along
uh mxd the draft protocol has been
established
by the work groups
thank you questions counselors
through your worship back on in appendix
a
um for elected members on page 38.
um pete you might be able to answer this
for me um at the very bottom of the page
where it talks the role or the
governance group
which i'm a member it says to provide
recommendation to the chief executive
of the council in respect to the
findings and conclusions are rising out
of this work group
noting that the decision-making
authority rests with the chief executive
and ultimately with council and so i'm
unclear about what that last part of the
statement means
i would have thought that the decision
making
did not leave rest with the chief
executive but it actually
arrested with the council in relation to
this governance group
through the chair any decisions made via
the pgd or else we need to be ratified
by council
correct but that doesn't mean the chief
executive does it it means council
as an elected members council
and totality it does say that the
recommendations get presented to the
chief executive
and it does say at the end the ultimate
decision making is with council and i
don't understand the bit that says
noting the decision-making authority
rests with the chief executive
through the chair if there's a wording
change required for clarity we can make
those changes
sure yeah look you know just
from a perspective counsellor in regard
to
pgg i think you can't have a situation
where the chief executive may have a
materially contrary view to what is
coming from
pgg so it allows for that opportunity
for
positioning but ultimately as the
council is the governors would rule i
could overrule the chief executive or in
this case
find a way pathway through so that's
i think pete in terms of the word
ultimately that
that effectively establishes this is the
council that ultimately makes the
decision
i wouldn't want us to get into a
position where we didn't have stuff
going through the chief executive
because there's operationally and
practical
reasons for some of the stuff to make
sure it works um
but ultimately the council was the one
to decide i think we should make it a
little bit clearer in terms of the work
yeah so i'd like to comment further
i wasn't attempting any shame form to uh
to undermine the chief visitor she's
part of this governance group
um and decisions and a set of
recommendations do go to her
as the first point of call i'm
happy for that clarification and further
discussion
questions well sorry you worship can i
just seek
clarification from from councillor clark
it's really just that that final line
yep that you're talking about sure we're
uh the decision-making authority and and
i think you're correct and what you're
trying to say
rests with ultimately with the council
okay through the chair there are six
recommendations
for this report you worship if no one
has any further comments i
i'll i'm prepared to move the
recommendations as a block
i would like to speak to uh
recommendation six
and and i would like to talk to the
media protocol as well
i'm happy to second those
recommendations
are you hearing us loud and clear yes
lord and clear thank you your worship
i just wanted to make a mention on the
media protocols i can see
the reasoning for it because of the past
events of
press releases etc and in those press
releases
uh to quote uh we did not play the ball
we played the man just quoting that
i feel a little bit sanitized in this
that's the word that i would use
sanitized and i just want to alert back
to
why we're here i'm not in favor of
preschool
i attend preschool but i'm not in favor
of it and that's the training sessions
and the other
many many little problems that we have
to talk to like
conduct and how to play the ball
etcetera
i go because i'm a team member but i
just want to make a comment on the
decisions of elected members i will
comment on that
i will comment on that from time to time
when it's necessary
and it will be based on policy and it
will be based on
issues it won't be an individual
character
assassination so i just wanted to make
that point
um i will when the need arises
talk to matters that i feel i should
yes i've got several issues in relation
to the media protocol um
the first question i'd ask of pete
saying he's a sponsor of
this is this protocol to determine the
behavior of elected members or is it
wider including
staff through the chair
the media protocols have been put
together as a result of
three or four recommendations that came
from the thompson report and as a result
of the work that the work group
for media protocols has undertaken
these media protocols relate
specifically to elected members
staff are covered by a
by a separate piece of work that's been
undertaken at the moment with regards to
a communication strategy development
okay my last my last issue is the
is bullet point bullet point 5
on page 43 so that state selector
members agree to focus on council issues
and activities
when speaking to the media rather than
on actions or decisions of elected
members
or staff i think our statement should
stop with a full stop at the end of the
word media
and the remaining part rather than
actions and decisions of elected members
should be deleted two rationales for
that
up at the very top of the media protocol
it
recognizes the right of members to speak
even when they have differing opinions
to be a minority
voice to speak against a majority
decision
the code of conduct that we have within
council
governs inappropriate comment against
elected members otherwise to go out and
talk to
about another member in a derogatory
manner i'd expect the code of conduct to
kick in
quite rightfully so that last bit as
lindsay abbott said
rather than the actions or decisions of
elected members or staff
gets to be very close to me to be a bit
of a gagging order
and i don't want that to be we have a
right to be quite open democratic about
what we do
and to be a minority voice if need be so
my recommendation
we should take out that last piece and
reword it
through the chair the intent of the
media protocol is not to
inhibit anything that would be
misaligned with our code of conduct
in terms of communicating with the media
i'm picking um that if i was to breach
that
for a mistake and i went out and said
we've made a majority decision
and i'm not happy with that and i want
to publicly state i'm not happy about
that
which could be in that second line which
is i'm criticizing the
decisions of elected members without
mentioning
that that in its own right could be a
code of conduct
um condition so they could say you've
actually breached an
protocol that we've agreed to so by my
agreeing to that i'm
really silenced and i'm criticizing any
collective decisions
and open to code of conduct where if
that line wasn't there
it's only my behaviour in the commenting
that would be
we've been i think lindsay said you play
the issue you don't play the
person that's behind the issue
thanks your worship um look i agree with
the the
point that councillor clark is making on
on that fifth bullet point and agree
that stopping at speaking to the media
is probably an appropriate space
he's correct and and that
what's dealt with in that second line is
is effectively also covered by a code of
conduct so it's it's something that
exists
i guess if if people want to execute the
right
to speak um publicly
against a decision of counsel you can
speak in opposition but what you cannot
do is rubbish it you can hold
a contrary view but you cannot um
ridicule
the the decision or the members that
have made it and i think that would
be the difference and and clarification
that you're looking for
i know all i'm doing is applying
broadcasting standards here and and the
right to freedom of expression
and the right to an opinion and in the
end we all want to be in a space where
we can accept that and we are often
anyway that people have
have a different opinion and that's
right um
i guess we need to be mindful of how we
accept the
democratic outcome councillor edmondson
thanks your worship
um i think these are good points that
are being raised and i guess um
the reason that second line is there to
remind councillors that
if in a situation where we people have
voted differently to
others that rather than speak about
how other people have voted and
criticizing them what you need to focus
on is
justifying why and how you voted the way
you did
and that's how you would play the ball
and not the man and i guess that
line is in there just as a reminder of
that
that it is actually to speak to the
issue and to
justify your own actions in position
without criticizing or belittling
or rubbishing somebody else's position
thank you mr grant thank you
your worship um firstly uh just on the
point
raised in regard to media training so
the people
through the working group was that the
media training uh councillor abbott was
it's um offered it's not compulsory
uh so on that basis it's for councillors
to take up but it is a reflection
of what was in the thompson report in
terms of this
can i just say council clark i mean
we could dance around on opinion in
terms of the wording here
but to be frank i have to say this again
is a reflection of behavior rather than
what the code of conduct might do so for
that reason
uh it's quite specific in saying as i
understand when in terms of the working
group
was to say that look if you're gonna up
uh
in terms of your commentary in the media
to the point of attacking
your colleagues or staff then this is a
matter we
would rather you reflect on before you
did so and i think
at the end of the day this is something
that
on behalf of the wider community
is an issue that has perpetuated over
the last 12 or 18 months i'm sorry to be
frank about it
but i do believe that it is quite
important to be quite
clear in terms of this uh will i accept
the code of conduct
this is asking you to preempt being
caught by the code of conduct
by thinking about how you approach your
comments in the market
it doesn't stop you from talking to the
media it doesn't stop you from
positioning yourself in terms as an
individual counselor versus the majority
but it does ask you to reflect in the
way you approach people's
uh in terms of comics so that's the
reason council
thank you that's right uh thanks to
worship just
uh as the chair of this working group um
i'd like to endorse everything that
grant uh mr grant has just been saying
um it isn't about trying to gag people
it is about
trying to have a positive effect on the
reputation of council i think we all
know that the things that we say
and do out in the public about council
and how it operates and what it does
and what we are doing ourselves can
often be reflected negatively in the
media both through social media
and through print media etc and
part of this working group's mandate is
to try and help us to
undo some of that damage we've been
doing a lot of work
to do good work as a council over the
last
couple of years and we actually need to
focus on the good work that we've been
doing
more so than the the
things that get under each other's skins
so yeah i support what's
written in this media protocols list i'd
also like to just mention that
while these bullet points kind of give
an indication of the things that we hope
to do like a no surprises policy etc
how that looks and what how we will
actually do that has yet to be
determined and that's the next phase
of this and counsellors will have an
input
into what kind of process or procedure
we want to have in place
to manage those things and also
just note that there's also a wider
communication strategy happening for the
organisation which will help us
to focus on those positive things that
the council is doing
because there are a lot of great things
happening out there and
it would be great if we can all focus on
those things
thank you any further discussion
questions
well i of course have to make a stand
for free speech
after uh in my youth i was
arrested for saying a word and um
it certainly was a salutary lesson
to me at how quickly
our freedoms can be lost and i know this
is
still open for discussion and amendments
but the perception will be it's passed
it's already passed and
we've listened to human rights which has
been
brought all over the world by military
regimes
and we want to do our little bit down
here
we're fortunate to be in the position we
are
and we should i think enhance that
situation that we find ourselves in
i'll put it to the vote all in favor hey
hi
i'd like it recorded your worship that
i'm opposed to uh
to append xd likewise please
um
maybe
next item is attendance at zones five
six
and the dia consultation on three waters
um councillors uh usually your
attendance at such events would be
considered
something that should come out of the
individual councillor's travel and
training budget
uh the reform of three waters is
considered to be the largest reform of
local government since 1989
having the largest impact in local
government since 1989
the dia are bringing a road show to
wanaka
on the 17th of march as the report in
front of you
says the there will be an opportunity at
zones five and six that agenda is not
yet out
to discuss it from a regional or
provincial suspect
perspective uh and then to stay on
so the recommendations are on the screen
in front of you
open for discussion debate worship i'm
happy to move the through
recommendations
or second days moved in second
discussion
and i find it a bit um
difficult to comprehend it it opens the
door for
the whole 12 councillors to all attend
this
roadshow if they wish now
when i first became law mayor here
uh we had to
give it we had to approach the mayor if
you wanted to go to a conference
or an event of any sort
and that meant that
the councillors who wanted to go
to say an event like this on three
waters
could do so but within
a financial limit so
you could only um because i didn't like
being put in the position of
being a mayor and i could choose who
could go
and so we
um said we looked at how much was in our
travel budget
and it meant that every councillor could
spend one i think it was one and a half
thousand
dollars on conferences
and it worked out well
and then suddenly that's
the amount allowed for has dramatically
increased and i know three waters is
of importance but so is
the pandemic and other crises we're
facing
thank you worship um respectfully this
is the most
uh ground-breaking situation that this
council has faced certainly in my
two terms now where are three waters
and potentially the removal of or the
centralization of
uh is going to remove a good
third of what this council council is
responsible for
so if even if all 12 of us stood up take
that opportunity to be there and
represent our community
at the front line then i think that that
is an absolute
investment that this council needs to
take um
and that is all i've got to say on the
matter thank you
thank you your worship um i'm going to
pretty much endorse what councillor
crackit said and point out that
number two offers the opportunity to all
elected members to attend on the 17th
that seems to me very legitimate a
number of us
made certain we attended because it was
so crucial the first three waters
consultation
which wasn't in vicargo last year
i believe it is such an important issue
that in fact we should all
if possible attend all those
consultations
it is absolutely and fundamentally the
biggest change
we will face as a council probably in
air
in our term the number three
as the actual zone conference
agenda is not yet out we don't know
whether there will be
a great deal of enthusiasm for attending
all three
days number three gives the ability if
councillors believe there is value when
we have seen the agenda
i would suggest that the greatest value
will be in attending the 17th which is
specifically the three waters matter and
i agree with councillor crackit and i'm
sure
others that that is a very legitimate
reason
every councillor around this table
should take every opportunity to be ok
with the three waters
suggestions
is there discussion questions
all right answers um yeah i agree what
the two
previous councils have said too it is an
important meeting on the 17th
um we had a presentation from the diac
in your manner
at the otago southern forum which was
only a couple of weeks ago so we've
probably got a relevant amount of
information and we'll probably just get
a repeat
i think the interesting thing for us as
councillors will be several things
which we didn't get two weeks ago and i
suspect we won't get again
and that is how big is the entity region
so governments decide they're going to
have five
regions so will our region be the whole
of the south island
or will we have two regions from the
south on don't have an answer to that
yet
um have asked for many months from the
dia
um who deals with the debt that we've
got loaded on our infrastructure
when the new entity takes ownership two
or three years from now
and that's unanswered because the
servicing is an important issue
how will how will the cost of the water
coming out of the entities
be levied so does that mean our rate
system will still have a
targeted levy for water and uh and the
money will then go to the entity and if
that's the case
we'll will we have no control of that so
if they push that up
we'll be will we be left accountable to
our ratepayers
with no ability to give any
justification for the increase
and and um the final issue was the issue
of
quite a few of the councils at the otago
southland forum
um we're going to go away and give some
thought to the out clause
so in this piece of legislation there is
an in clause
all councils have activated that they've
got a dollar for money for doing so
but there is an outclause as well which
means that local authorities
can stand alone if they want to and it
seems to me the implication for that
from the cargo may be
that uh we would not be in because we
actually have a very good system here
and then the car will compare to other
councils we seem to be way ahead of the
april
in our infrastructure investment and
management
and the other thing is that we could
avoid water meters which
seem to be on the horizon with the new
entity where you pay for what you use
um so i think there's a lot of
unanswered questions and maybe
at that conference we'll get some
answers
thank you further questions discussion
sorry counselor oh thank you worship um
i just wanted to
i guess um confirm what council clark
has to say that there are
so many questions and a lot that is up
in the air about the situation
that as a council we do need to be at
the forefront of
um it's it's just integral that we're
all there
there's a lot of assumptions or a lot of
what off what ifs being thrown around or
it could do this or it could be water
meters and that's when we're really not
at that point in the negotiations yet
so there's no no real point in putting
fear out there into the community that
we're going to be water metered at this
case
so let's just rein it back a little bit
make sure that we're at the
table to be there when we are
negotiating and
wait wait to worry on this one
thank you for the discussion if not put
it to the vote
all in favor say aye
now we move on to the miz report it's
rather short
but uh penny will be making her an
awkward speech
in wellington on march the
14th was it and uh
i wanted to pay a tribute to her as part
of this
news report um
i traveled extensively with penny
because she
believed our future was very dependent
on
on the overseas students
and so we traveled to singapore malaysia
indonesia
japan china vietnam
and for the world's fastest indian we
went to
salt lake city um
as a result of the interest we developed
the role of sit
um sword and they went from 2482
students to 13 290
students and i believe this was
a vital contribution that was made
to the development and to knocking back
the plunging roles that were happening
to
uh politics and
other institutes around the world
around new zealand
will be received put it to the vote all
in favor say aye
aye carried
worship there
of excluded is you could move into
public excluded but not have the public
leave
then break for afternoon tea before you
come back
for the reason set out on the agenda of
course of course
yes i'm thinking that thank you
put it to the vote
and now your worship you might like to
invite counsellor lush
if he'd like to have a photo or be
subjected to a photo for the media
and for everyone present to join you in
the committee room
for afternoon tea as part of
the celebration of luscious
you